طبعا هذا هذا هو دار بيت الاوبرا الذي تم
استهدافه
بالفتره الماضيه الحديث عن انخفاض وتيره
القص الاوكراني احمد على
المنطقه هنا لكن نتحدث عن 148 قذيفه
وصاروخ اوكراني سقط في المدينه خلال ال 24
ساعه الماضيه اصابه واحده ليست هناك ضحايا
لكن دائما ما يعني
تصاب بعض المباني السكنيه
والمرافق الحيويه في المدينه باضرار كما
نرى ربما هناك عوده للحياه في المدينه
نوعا ما نتيجه انخفاض اعداد القذائف
والصواريخ التي تسقط هنا لكن
الانخفاض هو جزئي وليس كبير نحن نتحدث
ايضا عن قصف روسي للمناطق التي تسيطر
عليها اوكرانيا ب 35 الف قذيفه وصاروخ
بشكل يوم ي على امتداد 100 كيلو متر مربع
المعارك هي تمتد ل 1000 كيلومتر مربع من
خرسون وصولا الى لوغانست كواسك لكن المئه
كيلو مربع الاخيره هنا في الشرق الاوكراني
هي التي تشهد زخم كبير
يعني بالقصف الروسي او القصف المتبادل اذا
صحه اذا صح التعبير ولو اختلفت المقاييس
والمقارنه كبيره بين الطرف